bonjour La voix est Libre en direct tous
les samedis sur France 3 avec
aujourd'hui 4 voies pour une question où
va la droite question que nous posons
pendant les militants UMP jusqu'à ce
soir et lisent de nouveau président de
leur partie en remercions Sébastien
Martin président UMP du Grand Chalon et
soutien de Nicolas Sarkozy et Stephen
Chevallier conseiller municipal UMP de
Dijon soutien de Bruno Le Maire d'avoir
accepté ce débattre en ce moment très
particulier avec aussi Nisrine Zaidi
vice-présidente socialiste du conseil
régional bonjour et Guillaume Maillard
adjoint maire de Nevers UDA bonjour à
vous bonjour et vous pouvez intervenir
vous l'avez déjà fait sur notre site
Internet et sur le réseau Twitter avec
les hashtags lvl Bourgogne et F3
Bourgogne alors bien sûr l'actualité
c'est le vote en ce moment même des
militants de l'UMP on l'a dit un vote
électronique exclusivement quand on dit
vote pour l'UMP on se souvient des
difficultés de l'élection Fillon Copé en
novembre 2012 c'était il y a juste deux
ans ça avait été compliqué aussi pour le
vote électronique à Paris
Sébastien Martin commence à se passe en
ce moment même on est dans en réalité on
sait qu'hier soir il y a eu quelques
difficultés oui hier soir ne plus
connaître quelques difficultés mais
aujourd'hui je crois que à l'heure à
laquelle je vous parle on a dépassé
largement les 20% de participation à
cette élection interne ça veut dire
qu'il y a une mobilisation de la part
des militants nous permanences sont
également ouvertes pour les personnes
qui souhaiteraient venir voter dans nos
permanences parce qu'il n'auraient pas
d'ordinateur de connexion internet chez
eux moi les informations dont je dispose
à l'heure à laquelle je vous parle c'est
que les choses se passent bien que la
mobilisation est importante et c'est
l'essentiel car il faut que le résultat
soit net ce soir Stephane chevalier sur
la Côte d'Or si vous avez les mêmes
informations écoutez j'ai exactement les
mêmes informations j'arrive à l'instant
de la permanence de Dijon et je peux
vous assurer que les militants se sont
déplacés nombreux contrairement à ce
qu'on aurait pu nous faire croire
on va en parler bien sûr la surprise de
cette élection d'une certaine manière
par rapport à un an c'est finalement d'y
voir Nicolas Sarkozy Nisrine zaibi on
l'attendait par la grande porte de la
présidentielle et finalement il revient
par la porte du parti de votre point de
vue et de point de vue socialiste
pourquoi effectivement moi j'avais une
question peut-être une interrogation à
vous poser je ne comprends pas comment
une majorité de militants et d'adhérents
d'un parti politique puisse aspirer à
mieux en soutenant un candidat qui a
quand même ruiné leur propre partie aux
dernières élections présidentielles ce
n'est pas rien une amende a été même
payée par le parti politique justement à
hauteur de plus de 360 000 euros ce qui
est quand même illégal en termes de code
électoral et d'ailleurs une encourt est
en quoi une enquête est en cours pour le
moment c'est 40000 de vos adhérents qui
ont justement sorti leur propre chéquier
pour pouvoir justement rattraper ses
erreurs de gestion
moi ma question elle est toute simple
est-ce que vous êtes schizophrène
atteint parfois peut-être d'un trouble
de la mémoire ou tout simplement pire
encore peut-être sadomasochiste enfin je
sais pas je provoque mais je voudrais
avoir votre réaction là
on va faire répondre bien sûr les deux
représentants de l'UMP et puis je vous
donnerai la parole j'ai peur que si à
chaque fois que vous posez une question
madame zaïbi qu'elle vous répond par une
autre question le débat se pas très
intéressant
prolonge un petit peu la mienne
néanmoins néanmoins néanmoins moi je
crois qu'il faut respecter le choix des
électeurs et des militants on peut pas
être démocrate d'un côté et d'un autre
s'interroger sur les décisions que
prendront démocratiquement aujourd'hui
les militants de l'UMP et qui sont là
pour décider que ça plaise ou non aux
parties socialiste de l'avenir et de la
personnalité qu'il souhaite voir mise à
la tête de cette formation politique et
une fois encore ils le font en toute
liberté et en toute responsabilité et je
pense honnêtement que
il y a mieux à faire que de donner des
leçons je pense qu'il y a mieux à faire
que de se poser en inquisiteur vous
savez dans ce dans cette région
Bourgogne certains hommes de gauche de
votre famille politique se sont posées
en inquisiteur aujourd'hui il retourne à
l'école j'espère pour vous ça sera un
autre avenir Stéphane
chevalier-sarkozy après cette affaire
vous vous souvenez Bruno le vert qui va
dire se met dans une position plus tôt
d'intégrité par rapport à ce permettrait
quand même d'abord de répondre à notre
ami du Parti socialiste
je suis ravi de savoir que vous
inquiétez de ce qui se passe dans votre
position vous avez raison de vous en
inquiéter parce que nous sommes en train
de nous réorganiser pour reprendre dans
deux ans les rênes de ce pays que vous
mettez à mal de jour en jour
alors effectivement moi j'ai fait le
choix de Bruno Le Maire parce que
je crois au renouvellement des
générations Nicolas Sarkozy a été
président de l'UMP en 2004 et je crois
qu'il est nécessaire
d'organiser ce renouvellement et puis
d'autres raisons évidemment m'ont poussé
à soutenir sa candidature depuis deux
ans nous souffrons de ces guerres de
cette guerre des chefs de cette de ce
manque de transparence financière et je
crois qu'on a besoin de changement au
sein même de l'UMP Guillaume Meyer quand
on est à l'UDI on va dire chez les
cousins par rapport à l'UMP comment
comment vous regardez cette élection
interne et en particulier le retour de
Nicolas Sarkozy qui veut reprendre la
tête du parti alors on va en parler bien
sûr mais qui a un certain nombre
d'affaires qui sont pas réglées et puis
que c'est quelqu'un qui a perdu les
présidentielles de la dernière fois
oui alors je veux pas commenter les
élections internes de l'UMP à l'UDI nous
sortons nous-mêmes de notre élection
interne ou un nouveau président a pris
la présidence de l'UDI dans la
continuité de Jean-Louis Borlo
concernant l'UMP le retour de Nicolas
Sarkozy Nicolas Sarkozy c'est l'ancien
président de la République il a une
grande expérience on peut le critiquer
ne pas l'aimer son expérience est un
vrai atout pour le parti maintenant les
affaires les problématiques
d'endettement de l'UMP je suis pas
habilité à commenter ces problèmes je
pense que c'est un problème interne
parti et je rejoins votre commentaire
que chacun s'occupe de ses propres
problèmes et tout ira bien concernant
concernant le retour de Nicolas Sarkozy
mais écoutez on a on a dirigé le pays à
l'UDI au côté de Nicolas Sarkozy donc il
y a pas de pas de problème à l'UDI
aujourd'hui j'ai une question à vous
poser quand on voit la campagne qu'on
fait à la fois Nicolas Sarkozy et Bruno
Le Maire on a l'impression qu'ils
veulent Sarkozy est allé chercher ses
militants et pour aller chercher les
militants de l'UMP il a tenu un discours
on va dire plutôt basé sur l'autorité
sur l'identité est-ce que ça signifie
que le cœur militant de votre partie il
est plutôt sur la droite de l'échiquier
de la droite par rapport à l'ensemble
des électeurs de la droite parce que
c'est vraiment ça qu'il a cherché
Nicolas Sarkozy dans son discours je
crois que d'abord un ce qui est
important c'est que les militants ils
attendaient que à nouveau on fasse un
peu de militantisme dans ce parti les
meetings de Nicolas Sarkozy on nous
expliquait que la campagne était
poussive qu'elle ne démarrait pas des
meetings avec 3000 personnes je connais
pas un responsable politique aujourd'hui
qui réunit 3000 personnes dans une salle
il y en a pas donc la campagne pussy la
campagne le retour qu'on nous a donné
c'est difficile je ne le vois pas
ensuite sur le positionnement sur lequel
vous vous essayez d'aller moi je crois
que non mais je crois que ce qui compte
demain au contraire c'est que on a deux
ans devant nous pour ne pas faire ce
qu'a fait la gauche pendant deux ans
quand elle était dans disposition pour
définir une ligne politique et
stratégique claire et clairement
identifié on a deux ans pour travailler
pour être arrivé devant les Français en
2017 avec un programme sérieux crédible
et cohérent et ce programme sérieux
crédible et cohérent il est pas
forcément très à droite très au centre
très à gauche où vous voulez il est
construit et travailler avec les
militants les membres de notre partie et
pour autant Bruno Le Maire vous allez
répondre bien sûr Bruno Le Maire il
s'est positionné différemment dans cette
campagne Stéphane chevalier d'abord sur
l'organisation et le déroulement de
cette élections internes effectivement
Nicolas Sarkozy et Bruno Le Maire n'ont
pas fait du tout la même campagne Bruno
Le Maire a fait le choix de d'aller au
coeur des fédérations d'aller rencontrer
j'allais dire les militants qui est
presque un par un je regrette d'ailleurs
que Nicolas Sarkozy n'est pas organisé
de meeting ou de réunion publique ni en
Bourgogne ni en Franche-Comté il était
question qui viennent à un moment on en
avait parlé écoutez je lis la presse
comme vous effectivement il était
question qui qu'il se déplace en
Bourgogne je le regrette maintenant pour
le positionnement je crois que Bruno Le
Maire a mené une campagne avec des idées
particulièrement claires nous souhaitons
que l'UMP soit un parti 100% à droite
voilà c'est court tout de même mais
c'est court non je crois que c'est
plutôt clair
on peut évoquer la fusion
umpudie si on veut parler de
positionnement clair au niveau de l'UMP
nous on a fait le choix de dire qu'on ne
souhaitait pas de fusion avec l'UDI
parce que fusion veut dire confusion
l'UDI aujourd'hui à la vocation de
rassembler une partie des centristes je
crois qu'aujourd'hui l'UMP doit
véritablement d'abord rassembler sa
famille celle de la droite nous sommes
alli vous lui répondez
effectivement je ne suis pas là oui en
général mais je ne suis pas là non plus
pour attaquer le parti en tant que tel
je n'ai pas cette prétention là mais
vous m'avez posé la question justement
du retour de Nicolas Sarkozy ce qui est
un homme les idées c'est différent on
peut avoir un débat idéologique sur les
idées et moi ça m'intéresse beaucoup
plus que de parler des personnes
justement mais Nicolas Sarkozy on me
demande de venir à une table ronde
justement aujourd'hui où le thème est où
va la droite je suis membre du Parti
socialiste donc si je ne parle pas de ça
de quoi je vais parler effectivement bon
moi je voudrais simplement revenir sur
un sujet particulier oui oui non mais je
voudrais simplement savoir déjà vous
parler de bilan de la gauche etc d'une
catastrophe enfin moi je voudrais déjà
avoir le bilan de Nicolas Sarkozy parce
qu'il est même pas il est même pas là il
est pas enfin on l'a pas on n'a pas les
éléments il en a même pas fait son bilan
et il se présente aujourd'hui c'est vos
affaires internes je le conçois et tant
mieux pour vous si vous en êtes d'accord
et d'ailleurs 80% de vos militants sont
apparemment favorables à son retour
j'espère juste de mon humble avis et pas
du Parti socialiste pas de la vie du
parti socialiste mais du mien j'espère
qu'un Bruno Le Maire l'emportera
aujourd'hui toute simple tout simplement
pour des raisons de valeur républicaine
à vie personnelle et pas du Parti
socialiste je dis que Bruno Le Maire
représente beaucoup plus une France
Gauliste qu'un certain Nicolas Sarkozy
qui a tenu un discours très stratégique
ces derniers temps et jeudi soir cela on
a bien vu les deux discours quand même
qui montre clairement une dérive de la
part de Nicolas Sarkozy vers des propos
pardonnez-moi d'être provocatrice mais à
la limite du Front national du populisme
ambiant et d'ailleurs cette très
stratégique de sa part mais c'est assez
schizophrénique aussi comment va-t-il
faire en 2017 pour convaincre l'ensemble
des Français tout à l'heure on parlera
aussi des primaires on parlera des
primaires vous vous dites qu'à un moment
donné ça concerne les affaires internes
du parti mais si vous vous amenez à
travailler sur les questions des
primaires il va falloir aussi
s'intéresser à la vie des gens qui vous
entourent et dont aussi et peut-être les
sympathisants de gauche ou autre puisque
c'est des primaires ouvertes alors on va
venir
d'abord quand même un mot de Guillaume
Maillard puisque le mot udi a été
prononcé
on a on a proposé un titre qui est
ouvert à la droite la droite dans son
ensemble Guillaume Mayer vous vous êtes
à l'UDI vous n'êtes pas à l'UMP et
finalement on pourrait vous poser la
question de cette manière là pourquoi
vous êtes à l'udié et pas à l'UMP
simplement parce que je me sens bien à
l'UDI lui permettra de comprendre la
différence
démocrate est indépendant donc c'est un
parti qui maintenant existe dans le
paysage politique les dernières
élections municipales nous ont permis
d'avoir de plus en plus d'élus que ce
soit au poste de conseiller municipaux
d'adjoint et de maire les dernières
sénateurs royales ont montré que uni
avec l'UMP nous avons réussi à gagner le
Sénat donc l'UDI a toute à toute intérêt
à travailler avec son Élie naturelle qui
a du MP nous sommes un mouvement de
centre droit maintenant nous avons des
valeurs qui nous différencient et je me
sens bien dans ma famille politique ce
n'est pas pour autant que on n'a pas
tout intérêt à travailler ensemble
puisque Unis de toute façon c'est la
seule possibilité pour aujourd'hui
proposer un projet alternatif au pays
quand je vois la situation actuelle de
la France je me dis qu'il est urgent
qu'on travaille ensemble et qu'on
construise les années à venir
complètement dans ce qui vient d'être
dit on voit très bien que quand droite
et centre droit sont unis travail de
concert main dans la main alors la
victoire est au bout il faudrait juste
vous donner un chiffre aux dernières
européennes si on avait fait des listes
d'union
UMP
udi en additionnant les deux scores on
était bien devant le Front National et
on n'aurait pas eu tous les commentaires
que l'on a pu avoir ensuite sur le front
national soi-disant pour mes parties de
France c'est 70 000 adhérents de Front
national le FBC 270 000 adhérents je
sais pas exactement le nombre de
d'adhérents parti socialistes donc sans
doute autant vous abordez la suite de
notre débat finalement qui est le périmé
le parti et le périmètre Nicolas Sarkozy
a dit je veux casser l'UMP c'est fini en
gros Bruno Le Maire dit on va garder
l'UMP
de votre point de vue est-ce qu'il y a
le temps est-ce que c'est une bonne idée
Stephen chevalier et bien sûr vous nous
direz Sébastien Martin mais position de
Bruno Le Maire c'est de dire on doit
garder l'UMP et moi je suis un peu
provocateur est-ce que l'UMP c'est un
parti qui a été créé pour
accéder au pouvoir pour des gens est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui il existe encore l'UMP
vraiment le MP existe encore la preuve
aujourd'hui même les militants se
déplacent pour choisir leur président
l'UMP c'est aussi les élections du mois
de mars et Sébastien Martin ne va pas me
contredire combien de têtes de liste
étaient rues de La Boétie pour aller
chercher
l'investiture de l'UMP c'est donc que
cette étiquette elle marche elle a un
sens elle a une clarté elle a une âme
derrière il y a des militants l'UMP on
souhaite en garder le nom pourquoi parce
que encore une fois voilà c'est c'est un
nom c'est une âme ce sont des militants
et très clairement on n'a pas d'argent
ni de temps à consacrer à un changement
non consacrons-nous directement au
programme il nous reste deux ans avant
la présidentielle on a beaucoup de
travail voilà gardons le nom de l'UMP
mais la vision d'un parti plus vaste qui
engloberait aussi le centre droit
c'est ça aussi que vous ne voulez pas
parce que c'est ça qui a proposé Nicolas
Sarkozy aussi
UMP aujourd'hui rassemble des
conservateurs des libéraux des chrétiens
démocrates quelques centristes
les adhérents qui sont à l'UMP c'est
qu'ils ne souhaitent pas être à l'UDI et
les adhérents qui sont à l'udient ce
qu'ils ne souhaitent pas être à l'UMP
gardons leur cette forme d'indépendance
respectons les militants
l'UMP c'est la droite avec un certain
nombre de centrices et lui dit
représente c'est vrai en majorité le
centre Guillaume Maillard il y a
possibilité de vivre les uns à côté des
autres de s'allier et de parce que
honnêtement aujourd'hui j'espère que le
débat va pas tourner autour des
étiquettes des noms d'étiquettes des
rassemblements des parassemblements moi
ce qui m'importe aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
n'oublie pas que quand on est élu et
c'est le cas autour de la table on est
élu par le peuple pour travailler pour
notre pays on est élu pour travailler
sur un projet travaillant sur le projet
les projets ont montré des belles
victoires aux dernières municipales les
rassemblements que ce soit Nevers que ce
soit dans le Grand Chalon que ce soit
ailleurs ont montré que ensemble on
pouvait gagner je pense que les
prochaines échéances vont montrer que
ensemble nous pourrons construire mais
arrêtons de discuter des étiquettes
alors après est-ce que Bruno Le Maire
souhaite une indépendance de l'UMP de
l'UDI Nicolas Sarkozy souhaite une
grande famille rassemblée il y a
d'autres acteurs aussi à l'umpcent
aujourd'hui nous nous avons notre propre
vie politique que nous avons un nouveau
président Jean-Christophe Lagarde qui a
qui insuffle une nouvelle dynamique qui
n'est pas pour non plus le rapprochement
au-delà d'un certain point aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est un peu prématuré
laissons laissons l'UMP et lire son
nouveau président nous nous changés de
de président il y a forcément y avoir
des discussions des échanges le but
étant de étant de construire je pense
que Jean-Christophe Lagarde
vous avez vécu de près à 9h la
difficulté de s'entendre avec l'UMP
Guillaume vous vous doutiez que j'allais
vous en parler bien sûr je m'en doutais
écoutez ça fait partie ça fait partie de
l'apprentissage politique et une fois de
plus je suis le premier à avoir été très
peiné de ces bagarres d'étiquettes si
vous me permettez le
propos on assiste rassembler on a su
travailler derrière un projet never à
venir qui est un projet sans étiquette
on a su travailler pour une ville
aujourd'hui ça fonctionne ça montre
aussi que le rassemblement peut
permettre des beaux projets après
j'insiste nous devons nous concentrer
sur l'avenir de notre pays et arrêter
d'user les plateaux de télévision et les
radios à discuter de nos étiquettes si
vous permettez
chez nous pour l'instant
l'unité rassemblement doivent être
forcément le mettre mot de la nouvelle
famille politique que l'on construira
demain je l'espère enfin pourquoi je
pense qu'il faut
rejoindre l'UDF avait rejoint le RPR
finalement le centre droit a eu une
tendance logique à sortir de la famille
parce que ce qui représente Guillaume
Maillard c'est juste l'ancienne UDF qui
au bout d'un moment n'a plus été
satisfait d'être dans une famille ou sa
parole n'était pas entendue on peut le
dire comme ça je sais pas si on peut le
dire comme ça en tout cas ce que je vois
c'est que on a eu une imp qui a permis
un moment ou un autre de gagner un
certain nombre de suffrages parce
qu'elle avait su faire un grand
rassemblement que il y avait des gens
comme Jean-Louis Borloo en ce sein qu'il
y avait des gens comme Pierre ménorris
en son sein et que tout ça c'était la
bonne dynamique et que pourquoi il faut
repartir à zéro parce que honnêtement
depuis nous avons subi des défaites
depuis nous voyons les jours nos
concitoyens s'éloignaient un peu plus de
la vie politique de la vie militante
est-ce qu'on peut raisonnablement
considérer que on va simplement relancer
la machine et qu'elle va repartir je ne
le crois pas moi je pense qu'il faut
réinventer la manière de faire vivre
notre formation politique de la droite
et du centre demain et que ça doit
passer sans doute par un nouveau nom ça
doit passer sans doute aussi par de
nouvelles pratiques au sein du parti
plus de transparence plus d'indépendance
financières un certain nombre d'éléments
plus de paroles donné aux militants
aussi et ça on doit le faire dans une
maison nouvelle voilà ma position moi je
voudrais simplement rebondir sur le nom
effectivement on a ces débats aussi aux
parties socialiste Manuel Valls a évoqué
l'idée de peut-être changer le nom du
parti socialiste pour moi j'ai
l'impression finalement oui pour moi
l'impression que j'ai à titre personnel
c'est une stratégie de marketing
politique faire oublier aux gens
justement de par un nom
non c'est pas ça je me pose aussi des
questions au sein de mon propre parti
c'est normal il faut pas non plus être
hostile au changement mais à un moment
donné c'est la question l'inquiétude que
je me pose c'est clairement voilà Espa
une stratégie vraiment de marketing
politique parce qu'à un moment donné
quand Nicolas Sarkozy dit je rejette le
système des parties mais par contre il
se présente à une
justement la présidence du parti c'est
un peu ce qu'ils ont encore une fois
pardonnez-moi mais c'est simplement ce
commentaire que j'avais à faire
juste pour
pour rebondir sur ce que Madame vient de
dire vous devriez dans l'action dans la
réflexion en ce moment puisque il me
semble que vous êtes au pouvoir et
qu'aujourd'hui le pays a besoin d'action
a besoin d'une stratégie et si vous
voulez qu'on en dépend
à nouveau pour parler de ça avec plaisir
nous avons du pain sur la planche à
droite pour remettre ce pays sur sur de
one voie j'ai une question à vous poser
concernant le la ligne directrice on va
dire certains observateurs de
politologues font remarquer que la
campagne en cours pour la présidence du
parti on en parlait tout à l'heure amine
en évidence une différence d'une
certaine manière entre
différence politique entre et j'y
reviens le cœur de l'UMP on sous qui
manifestement aurait apprécié plutôt la
campagne de Nicolas Sarkozy en 2012 ce
qu'on a appelé la ligne buisson et un
électorat de droite au sens large de
droite et du centre droit qui demande
autre chose et qui pourrait s'incarner
dans Bruno Le Maire mais peut-être aussi
dans Alain Juppé ou dans François Fillon
est-ce que l'UMP a besoin d'une
clarification sur ce sujet c'est le
grand mot de la pré mitterrandisse du
droit d'inventaire est-ce que il y a
besoin d'un droit d'inventaire à l'UMP
et vous avez de tout dans l'UMP et il me
faudra bien faudra bien suivre une ligne
à un moment donné vous avez de tout dans
l'UMP et le but du jeu c'est de faire en
sorte que chacun se sente bien dans
cette formation politique que l'on va
construire demain c'est ça l'objectif et
l'objectif c'est pas de se positionner
par rapport
à l'extrême droite d'un côté ou au
centre et à la gauche de l'autre la
question c'est de se positionner
par rapport à ce que nous sommes nous on
n'a pas à courir derrière les uns ou
courir derrière les autres moi le pour
moi l'objectif de ma famille politique
c'est que les gens adhèrent ma famille
politique au regard de ce qu'elle
représente je dois compter de ce qu'elle
porte que Nicolas Sarkozy a un peu couru
après d'autres personnes en 2012 et
l'UMP à son nombre de gens on trouvait
que Nicolas Sarkozy avait couru derrière
le Front national en 2012 clairement
Nicolas Sarkozy a fait en 2012 la
campagne qui la considéré avec la bonne
campagne malheureusement elle n'a pas
fonctionné elle a mené à une défaite et
un certain nombre de personnes autour de
lui d'ailleurs ont pu exprimer une
différence par rapport à cette à cette
campagne et notamment moi voilà et ça ne
me pose aucun problème ça nous pose
aucun problème parce que on a quelqu'un
qui accepte le débat aujourd'hui qui
accepte les différences au sein de sa
famille politique et qui à la volonté
d'avancer de rassembler c'est tout ce
que je vois et si on n'a pas cette
capacité à avancer à rassembler parce
qu'on a un peu d'autorité alors on fera
rien
je rejoint en partie les propos de
Sébastien Martin ce que je crois moi
c'est qu'on doit vite se remettre au
travail et c'est la raison pour laquelle
on souhaite conserver le nom UMP c'est
véritablement se remettre au travail dès
le dès le soir de l'élection du
Président que ce soit ce soir ou dans
une semaine d'ailleurs je souhaite
j'espère évidemment qui vient
encore une fois rendez-vous ce soir je
dirais soyons nous-mêmes soyons fiers
d'être de droite n'ayons pas de n'ayons
pas de complexe
et quand nous sommes au pouvoir faisons
un vrai programme de droite moi ce que
je regrette c'est que depuis deux ans
encore une fois il y a eu cette guerre
des chefs certains au sein de la famille
politique à laquelle j'appartiens n'ont
pas souhaité faire ce droit d'inventaire
je crois que c'est un tort on aurait dû
le faire
clairement on a presque perdu deux ans
et encore une fois c'est maintenant que
tout se joue
tournons-nous vers les Français il est
temps puisqu'on parle de position
Guillaume Maillard la ligne que choisira
la nouvelle UMP ou selon nouveau nom
pourrait porter c'est quand même ça peut
être une condition d'accord et de
discussions avec vous
oui enfin je pense que l'UMP est un
parti démocratique tout à fait
respectable
nous sommes allés depuis un certain
temps
de ça le danger il y a quelque chose il
y a quelque chose dans tactique
politique comme disait madame après
après le fond je pense le fond reste
fortement républicain et Dieu merci
je suis pas forcément Sarkozy tout au
départ par contre je personne n'en a
parlé il a quand même dirigé le pays au
cours d'une grande crise mondiale et je
pense qu'il a pris des décisions qui ont
permis aujourd'hui au pays de d'être où
il est on voit depuis 2012 à l'intérieur
de la situation
c'est pas simple de diriger le pays je
pense que il a pas sûrement pas fait
tout bien mais il a fait des choses je
pense qu'il y avait une vraie entente
européenne et internationale je suis
chef d'entreprise dans la vie on a vécu
de moment très difficile dans
l'industrie automobile je pense que on
peut lui donner cette au moins ce recul
cette expérience et quelque part cette
légitimité Bruno Le Maire à quelqu'un
que j'apprécie particulièrement qui est
tout à fait respectable et qui fait
partie de la nouvelle génération aussi
donc c'est comme c'est comme à l'UDI on
a on a la garde qui est maintenant notre
nouveau président il y a eu des il y a
eu un premier tour un deuxième tour
maintenant il faut être rassemblé
derrière lui et il faut qu'on discute
avec nos amis mais surtout discutons du
projet pensez aux Français je répète ce
que je disais tout à l'heure
nous sommes élus pour travailler pour
nos territoires pour travailler pour
notre pays il y a trop de temps de
perdus à mon sens les générations quadra
comme on dit il est important que l'on
agisse pour que les gens recouvrent à la
politique pour que les sympathisants
soient mobilisent et qu'on arrête de
voir ces extrêmes montées et qui
commence vraiment à m'inquiéter à titre
à titre privé et à titre politique c'est
les deux points dont on va parler en
particulier effectivement l'éventualité
de primaire quand vous parlez de
participation démocratique un mot quand
même avec humour nihrings et vie c'est
que on a reprocha François Hollande
d'être allé chercher ses électeurs sur
un terrain qui sur un programme qui
n'est pas celui qui l'applique
maintenant est-ce que c'est pas aussi ce
qui arrive à tout parti d'opposition
quand il a besoin de se rassembler
finalement avec humour parce que c'est
un petit peu ça ce dont on parle en
creux en ce moment justement si vous
voulez qu'on débattre de ce sujet avec
plaisir
vous venez de le rappeler mais pour
rebondir à ce que monsieur vient de dire
effectivement sur le bilan de Nicolas
Sarkozy il a tenu un discours assez
marrant quand même il en responsabilité
et tout ce qui dit toutes les promesses
qui tient lors de ces discours
finalement qu'a-t-il fait pendant son
mandat il était en responsabilité il
avait la chance d'être à la tête d'un
pays et il n'a pas su faire pourquoi
revient-il je ne blâme pas et je ne
remets pas en question la totalité de
son bilan parce que ça serait très
caricatural de dire qu'il a été dans
l'échec total non il faut reconnaître
aussi certaines choses et je rejoins
encore une fois mon collègue ici présent
mais par contre quand il tient un
discours sur l'Europe comme je veux que
l'on supprime 50% des compétences de
l'Europe actuelle le reste doit être
rendu aux États je suis désolé mais il
faudrait lui préciser quelles sont ses
compétences européennes et lui dire
aussi que les États eux-mêmes ont
volontairement consenti à ses
attributions à l'Europe donc il y a
aussi encore une fois une incohérence
dans ces propos c'est pour ça que je
tenais simplement à souligner ça de dire
mais où va-t-il parce que pour nous on
est peut-être des acteurs extérieurs à
ce parti mais on observe et on écoute
attentivement les discours qui sont
tenus par des personnalités comme
Nicolas Sarkozy et moi j'aimerais
simplement y voir clair dans tout ça
c'est ça revenir sur François Hollande
effectivement le bilan le bilanage quand
même entre une campagne et l'exercice
effectivement les lacunes qu'on a
nous-mêmes en ce moment même dans notre
partie socialiste mais comme le dit
encore une fois notre collègue il faut
dépasser aussi ses clivages j'attaque la
droite j'attaque la gauche la montée du
Front national elle se fait comme ça
aussi il faut aussi sur dépasser un peu
ces clivages politiques pour parler
plutôt aux Français de l'intérêt qu'on
peut leur porter moi si vous voulez
qu'on parle du bilan de François
Hollande justement un mi-mandat parce
qu'on est que seulement à deux ans
d'exercice moi j'aimerais bien qu'on
laisse aussi le temps au temps à un
moment d'un mandat et là on pourra faire
le bilan parce qu'on n'a pas oui voilà
ça sera l'occasion d'un autre débat
parce que là actuellement on parle du
bilan de Nicolas Sarkozy moi j'attends
toujours une un inventaire quoi
clairement un résumé du bilan de Nicolas
avant les informations de midi mais pour
dire que bien sûr on continue se débat
juste après vous répondrez on parlera
aussi de l'éventualité des primaires à
l'UMP et peut-être un petit peu du front
du Front national non c'est trop tard
c'est midi ce sera juste après vous
répondrez